he is the head of the American Center
for Law and Justice and the president's
counsel Jay Sekulow is with us all right
I don't only want one for this I won't
want ya on the dossier Fusion GPS he's
meeting with them Bruce or his wife
works for them doing anti-trump research
for in the lead-up to the campaign what
about the fix being in with James Comey
and Peter struck Peter struck and Lisa
page both anti-trump Pro Hillary what
that would reopen the entire email
investigation because they exonerated
before they investigated and then I'm
not even talking about uranium one and
and surveillance that I'm asking Jay you
know how about all of this needs to be
investigated well the last you mentioned
is something I mean they're all serious
but the last one you mentioned I mean
the idea that it may well be that this
dossier put together by fusion GPS and
Christopher steel and and now Bruce ORS
wife whom Brewster workhorse was fourth
ranking official at the Department of
Justice may served as the basis upon
which a FISA warrant was issued remember
that first time they went from that FISA
warrant it was turned down then they get
it later was it based on this and if it
was based on this I mean you're talking
about the fruit of the poisonous tree I
mean this whole idea that this would
somehow you know it could even exist
within our system of justice frankly is
astonishing but you you look at these
interconnections and this is really
serious to the operation of justice
that's so possible that Hillary Clinton
and then Hillary Clinton's campaign and
the she's controlling the Dean's DNC
according to Donna Brazile that herb
bought and paid for Russian propaganda
dossier with all the salacious details
that that could have been used to issue
a FISA warrant against candidate Trump
president-elect Trump and his entire
team now legally speaking if that
happened wouldn't that render any
information that they received out of
that under false pretenses yeah meet
more legal pretenses yes I mean if if in
fact when there's a lot of chatter about
this if in fact the FISA warrants were
issued based on this unverified as James
Comey said salacious dossier which we
know is there's no verification of any
of it was not nothing and it is correct
if that in fact was the basis upon which
the FISA warrant was issued well then of
course you have a a constitutional issue
which is can the evidence derived from
that FISA warrant which resulted in
unmasking be admissible and I think the
answer clearly would be no next question
of constitutional issues Criminal
Procedure issues and I think it puts
look this whole and masking scandal as a
scandal in and of itself but to put it
in perspective if it was based on that
dossier what have we come to what is the
court system allowed itself to get to do
you agree with my analysis based on the
May 2nd or early May draft by James
Comey and then also edited by Peter
struck the anti-trump guy that worked in
the FBI that was involved in all these
cases there's does that in any way the
fix being in before they investigate it
even talked to Hilary or witnesses that
sounds to me like obstruction of justice
by Jimmy they granted immunity I mean
they granted immunity to witnesses and
this exoneration letter was written
before they interviewed the exonerate of
the witnesses that were granted immunity
so go figure that out I mean what
prosecutor does that and then if you
look at the actual and we broke this out
Shawn if you look at what was drafted by
James Comey and his draft and that was
edited by Peter schrock and others you
look at things like there was a big
discussion remember the whole basis upon
which this whole email situation came to
light was the fact that the server was
not secured that it was located in a
town house in Colorado in James commis
original draft when talking about the
seriousness of this he says this is
especially concerning because all of
these emails were housed on servers not
supported by full-time security staff
like those found at the department and
agencies of the United States government
that was omitted from the final report
he wrote it and then someone took that
out and that was the basis upon which
this whole matter started in the first
place all right now let me go back to
our top story tonight
we now have John Solomon's explosive
report and
what we're seeing is an intensity and
and financial rewards going up and up
and up
starting in October where it you know
first ten thousand fifty thousand
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
then we get to two days before the
election seven hundred and fifty
thousand dollars that we don't know
where the money came from but being
offered to a woman in exchange for her
quote story about Donald Trump if that
story can come out I doubt we would have
known it was paid for because we didn't
know that anybody was being paid up
until today you got to help me through
this what that would mean in terms of
trying to influence the American people
to 48 hours before they go to the polls
well look I mean if you look at the
entire situation you put all of this
into context what was what was taking
place here these were you have opted
look campaigns are rough business
everybody understands that but what you
had going on in in the John Solomon's
piece in the hill is this escalating
value of these stories as the election
gets closer and then the de-escalation
of that value when the election is over
and you look at some of the train of
emails that cited in there you see how
this goes and was interesting the
personal it was offered the $750,000 as
John reported didn't take the money and
anticipated all of this phony Russian
lies salacious lies they're paid for by
Hillary Clinton Russian connection
collusion if you will now you have two
days before the election a massive sum
of money for somebody to make an
accusation that can't possibly be vetted
in that period of time well because what
you have is it's shown and this is that
you look at the whole process you talk
about the need for a special counsel
look at all of this that's going on and
then you go back to the Department of
Justice itself in the epyon and like you
I have tremendous respect for the agents
that put their lives on the line for us
every single day defending this country
defending our Liberty defending our
freedom but I'll tell you what I don't
appreciate I don't appreciate a
Department of Justice that not only had
determined the case before the evidence
came in but was completely and it's
become very
here conflicted on multiple levels and
that is not I don't care if you're
Republican Democrat independent no one
in our constitutional republic should
take that as okay it's not okay and I
think Chris Ray's got a big job to do
the head of the FBI in in this is by the
way you know we talk about the deep
state you don't dig so deep for this
this is right at the surface
these are leadership issues and I was
glad to see that General Sessions today
said that they're taking this issue
seriously of a special counsel there was
a reason I said it and that was all yeah
but you know what there's a process they
go through they need to go through that
process in valuating special counsel jay
sekulow thank you for being with us